es geht voran meine damen und herren in
berlin wird seit gestern endlich
offiziell rumpelt ampel
koalitionsverhandlungen und von wegen
jedem anfang wohnt ein zauber inne sagt
naja im konkreten fall waren die
flitterwochen ziemlich schnell vorbei es
ist wirklich so nur stunden
stunden nach dem ersten weg du mit mir
gehen haben sie schon öffentlich
gestritten über keine ahnung ostsee
pipelines oder ministerposten ja erst
schickt linda irgendwelche fdp büttel
vor die sagen machen wir den linken ein
geiler finanzminister kurz danach sagen
irgendwelche grüne natürlich dasselbe
über habe und ich dachte die ampel war
anders weniger macht politik dafür weiß
er mehr aufbruch
modernisierung freie liebe mut zum
pathos
lange zeit hat es keine vergleichbare
modernisierungs chance gegeben wir sind
in einer hoffnungs zeit angekommen hier
ist ein aufbruch möglich einen aufbruch
in einer fortschritts koalition eine art
fortschritts freundliches zentrum eine
echte dynamik hoffnung des fortschritts
für eine modernisierung eine hoffnungs
zeit die wir nicht enttäuschen wirklich
ganz ohne zweifel wäre eine ampel
koalition an ihrem beginn ein
zweckbündnis
das klingt hart aber er hat ja recht
sind sie keine partner mehr übrig das
kennt jeder von uns aus der disco
morgens um fünf mal dass reste koalieren
problem echtes problem wenn man ständig
wie die hier von der transformation der
gesellschaft redet muss man am ende
tatsächlich irgendetwas transformieren
es ist so klein klein reicht jetzt nicht
mehr große reformen müssen her im ampel
sondierung papier steht so etwas vom
beschleunigten kohleausstieg aber dann
heißt es wörtlich
idealerweise gelingt das schon bis 2030
idealerweise ist ein wort das man
idealerweise in solchen papieren nicht
lesen möchte ja sehr schwammig warte mal
was steht hier noch irgendjemand sollte
dringend mal den öffentlichen nahverkehr
stärken das finden wir als regierung
unter umständen ganz nah also denke ich
da ergibt wenn sich
so aus den sondierungen ist die fdp für
mich eindeutig als sieger hervorgegangen
kein tempolimit keine steuererhöhungen
kein konzept wie man co2 preise sozial
abfedern also ist ausdrücklich nicht
böse gemeint aber waren die grünen
besoffen als sie das unterschrieben
haben leute wirklich jetzt
lasst euch doch nicht so über den tisch
ziehen lindner hier der gewiefte hund
will finanzminister werden weil das der
schlüssel zur kasse ist das ist wahre
macht die grünen werden abgespeist mit
einem neuen klima ministerium so wie man
früher eingeborene mit glasperlen
verarscht hat
die kriminalpolizei warnt immer wieder
fallen r klasse grüne bei ampel
gesprächen auf den sogenannten fdp trick
rein und er geht so dieses arbeitslose
peek & cloppenburg model beansprucht für
sich selbst das mächtige
finanzministerium und sagt dann zu den
grünen dafür kriegt er ein nagelneues
klimaministerium doch vorsicht wer hier
einzieht hat nicht mehr zu sagen als
diese umweltministerin die jetzt schon
keiner mehr kennt oder diese aus der
später auch nichts geworden ist voll
fies und wenn der beschiss versuch auf
liegt sagt der dreiste betrüger
wer s glaubt die große revanche unser
thema bei vorsicht falle nepper
schlepper bauernfänger
naja nicht
wirklich
zufrieden die koalitionsverhandlungen
haben gerade erst angefangen
und wer weiß vielleicht wird die ampel
ja noch ein transformieren des zukunfts
fortschritts dings oder so denn die
bürger wollen ja zumindest laut umfragen
modernisierung wollen sie man muss die
bürger nur jetzt mit den richtigen
worten ich sag mal
inspirieren und begeistern mit der
regierung die da gebildet werden soll
kann auch ein großer aufbruch für unser
land entstehen
kann muss aber nicht ja olaf scholz das
gesicht zum aufbruch sagen wir mal
immerhin sind die ampel musen sich einig
es muss investiert werden in deutschland
50 milliarden mindestens pro jahr für
digitalisierung bildung und klimaschutz
also das sind im prinzip nur noch
winzige detail fragen offen so was wie
wo kommt das geld her
wie zaubert man den geldberg bei den
gigantischen das ist die frage in
wirklichkeit freunde reden wir ja auf
die nächsten zehn jahre gerechnet von
500 milliarden gut das klingt für den
laien viel aber der alte zahlen fuchs
olaf scholz ist sich sicher dass das wir
das bisschen was wir zusätzlich an
finanzspielraum brauchen finden das 40
und ergeben eben das bisschen die paar
kröten die findet der urlaub zur not
beim putzen einer sofaecke ja natürlich
so klar zur realität eine möglichkeit
wären staatlich gestützte
investitionsgesellschaften so dazu hat
die fdp bereits nein gesagt also bleibt
vor allem das streichen von subventionen
wir könnten zum beispiel endlich
aufhören jedes jahr acht milliarden für
diese blöden diesel subventionen zu
verballern ja dazu
überraschung hat die fdp bereits nein
gesagt gut dann lasst uns wenigstens das
idiotische dienstwagenprivileg streichen
brächte auch noch mal über drei
milliarden die hälfte der kohle geht an
das reichste fünftel der bevölkerung
hier kompromissvorschlag das
dienstwagenprivileg an sich bleibt aber
der abteilungsleiter der den wagen fährt
muss jeden morgen an der bushaltestelle
halten und andere steuerzahler
einsammeln die selber keinen dienstwagen
haben und so eine blöde cara
mitfinanzieren das ist fair und ganz
wichtig der auf dem beifahrersitz muss
unbedingt jeden morgen hart gekochte
eier essen einfach wegen dem geruch
ich selbst habe übrigens keinen
dienstwagen ich nutze den dienstwagen
eines chauffeurs das geht auch
ich bin wirklich mal sehr gespannt ob
das klappt mit den 50 milliarden pro
jahr wolfgang kubicki sagt zitat da sei
eben kreativität gefragt ja bravo
kreativität ist nämlich viel wichtiger
als rechnen können meint auch gernot
hassknecht
gernot hassknecht findet 50 milliarden
in nur 158 sekunden
leute ernsthaft wo ist das problem die
kohle haben wir ratz fatz zusammen wenn
alle mithelfen beispiel blutspenden
schon eine ladung rote schloss bringt 20
euro bedeutet wenn jeder deutsche nur 30
mal im jahr blut spendet haben wir 50
milliarden im sack pro kopf also gerade
mal 15 liter blut wie sie wie und warum
hat gott uns wohl zwei in ihren gegeben
nicht um eine davon zu verkaufen denkt
mal drüber nach oder hier sanitär bons
pisten für deutschland bevor ihr die an
der tanke direkt für sneaker fall löst
schenkel 50 cent felix den start die
reconf eine
fixe idee wie ich das bisher
sponsoring im reichstag wir ersetzen den
ollen adler endlich durch ein schönes
wiesenhof hähnchen und die heute heißt
auch gar nicht mehr reichstag sondern
hat voith arena
50 milliarden das sind doch peanuts
nächste geschäftsidee ab jetzt kann
jeder von uns markus söder buchen
schickt den verhaltensauffälligen danken
10 euro und er nimmt dir mit dem handy
persönliche geburtstagsgrüße auf hallo
andreas wahrscheinlich überrascht dich
direkt persönlich von mir zu hören hallo
angela wahrscheinlich überrascht dich
direkt persönlich vor
hallo angelika wahrscheinlich überrascht
es dich direkt persönlich von mir zu
hören hallo annika wahrscheinlich
überrascht schließlich direkt von mir
persönlich zu hören hallo anita
wahrscheinlich über das schließlich
direkt persönlich von mir hallo markus
du nervst vis
grüße vom söder das ideale geschenk für
menschen die man wirklich hast
wenn die ampel von 50 milliarden
brauchen warum kommen sie dann nicht auf
das naheliegende robert habeck heiratet
pacers und lässt sich direkt danach
wieder scheiden problem gelöst und wenn
euch das alles nicht seriös genug ist
können wir auch gerne den
spitzensteuersatz wieder auf 53 prozent
erhöhen wie damals unter diesem super
gefährlichen kommunisten geht nicht
der scw gut dann machen wir halt das mit
den sanifair box mir doch egal
leck mich alle
eins muss man der ampel lassen lieber
einzeln 7 läuft alles nach plan wird
olaf scholz wohl schon in der nikolaus
woche als neunter kanzler der
bundesrepublik deutschland vereinigt
olaf scholz ein mann der wenn man nur
lange genug über ihn nachdenkt allerhand
rätsel aufgibt herzlich willkommen zu
einer neuen folge von heute show me
story
[Applaus]
liebe zuschauer wer ist olaf scholz noch
nie haben wir über einen kommenden
kanzler so wenig gewusst wenn man den
man googelt erfährt man er joggt gerne
aber ohne dabei musik zu hören seine
leidenschaft ist lesen crazy und er
trinkt so gut wie keinen alkohol
also es gibt taliban-führer die sagen
das wäre mir zu langweilig
ein bisschen was wissen wir ja schon
über olaf scholz ich meine da war die
letzten jahrzehnte quasi immer dabei ach
ja
wir haben mal die klassenkameraden aus
seiner hamburger grundschule gefragt
niemand konnte sich an einen olaf
erinnern hier ein klassenfoto von damals
der besonders farblose in der mitte das
war er und wenn sie jetzt denken denn
habt ihr doch geburt nein nein so sah
der damals aus
hier seien hochzeitsfoto
dass scholz geheimnis ist konsequente
konturlosigkeit wer mit nichts auffällt
act auch nie an damit und mit seinem
ausgeprägten talent nicht armin laschet
zu sein wird er jetzt tatsächlich
kanzler oder glauben sie es lagert seine
rhetorischen brillanz müsste nicht eine
regierung eine gemeinsame vision haben
nein
was aber und jetzt muss spannend wenn
olaf scholz seine extreme langweiligkeit
nur vortäuscht um von einer anderen
dunklen seite abzulenken
[Musik]
er glaube ich nicht
mehr mit olaf hinter verschlossenen
türen verhandelt berichtet von einem
herrschen oberlehrer winfried
kretschmann zum beispiel hat mit ihm
2019 über einen höheren co2 preis
verhandelt und scholz habe das papier
der grünen
ostentativ in den papierkorb geworfen
nach meinen informationen hat er danach
noch den papierkorb angezündet und
wieder gelöscht
und dann den armen oper kretschmann in
den schwitzkasten genommen
entschuldigung wenn er diese dominante
cholerische seite hätte warum wissen wir
davon nichts warum weil er uns ganz
bewusst einschläft vor allem seine art
zu reden wirkt wie soll man das erklären
ich glaube wir müssen das fortsetzen
dass wir jetzt im november entwickelt
haben pauschalierte kostenerstattung
können da ein modell sein ich glaube das
ist auch das was wir eu-rechtlich und
unter allen anderen rechtlichen
gesichtspunkten am sinnvollsten
[Musik]
er setzt das als waffe ein also wer so
öde ist kann ja gar nicht empfinden
skandale verwickelt sein denkt man dabei
sammelt er die geradezu ich sage nur hsh
nordbank wirecard skandal comex und
warburg bank stimmt kommt auch im
schloss zusammen so und zwar so viel
dass ich nicht mehr an zufall glauben
frage was wenn olaf scholz in den
achtzigern von der ddr angeworben wurde
und mit diversen
bankenskandalen den kapitalismus bei uns
zu zerstören
jetzt wird es aber vogelwild hh finden
wie egon krenz mitglied des politbüros
und sekretär des zk der sed führte heute
in berlin ein gespräch mit einer
delegation des bundesvorstandes der
arbeitsgemeinschaft der jungsozialisten
in der spd
das ist ja furchtbar also die haare weil
ich das ja furchtbar
keine weiteren fragen
und nächste woche bei heute-show mystery
die spd und ihre doppelspitzen lüge sind
saskia esken und norbert walter borjans
vielleicht in wirklichkeit ein und
dieselbe person
[Musik]
nein weil er ihm aus vielen dank
so
aufnahme
hallo dies ist die automatische and card
von oliver welke und der heute show
leider ist das video schon vorbei ihr
könnt den kanal allerdings gerne
abonnieren und ein weiteres video
anschauen vielen dank so müsse jetzt für
immer reich